bonjour et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro de parlement hebdo compagnie de
mickaël zeze bonjour michael joe avec
une actualité parlementaire
particulièrement chargé cette semaine ya
d'abord eu la déclaration de politique
générale de jean marc ayrault à
l'assemblée une heure et demie de
discours pour exposer les futures
réformes du gouvernement
le vote de confiance a été l'occasion
pour le premier ministre
le conte et ses amis le mouvement jean
marc ayrault a poursuivi au cirque les
parlementaires direction le scénar vous
a ciblé son discours plus spécifiquement
sur les collectivités locales
il a également parlé cumul des mandats
un sujet sensible qui laisse augurer des
heures chaudes à la station enfin on à
paris cette semaine collectif budgétaire
en conseil des ministres il s'agit de la
loi de finances rectificatif pour 2012 8
milliards et demi d'euros de recettes ou
d'économies et l'année 2013 sera bien
plus dur encore c'est ce que prédit la
cour des comptes est avec nous pour
commenter toute cette actualité
politique et très parlementaire à la vie
d'alice mon jour mais ni chargé des
relations avec le parlement tout nouveau
ministre dans le gouvernement
r- semaine très chargée avec le discours
de politique générale alors au ps on dit
de vous que vous êtes le monsieur
travail de monsieur emploi fin
connaisseur en tout cas de ces deux
domaines
est ce à dire que vous êtes devenu
ministre des relations avec le parlement
par un peu par accident par accident on
voudrait poser la question à ceux qui
ont pris la décision je pense que
effectivement effet plutôt spécialisé
sur les questions sociales mais en même
temps vice président de la commission
des lois
j'ai aussi travaillé sur toutes les
questions de droit civil droit de la
famille
et puis bon j'avais une certaine
expérience parlementaire mais c'est vrai
que c'est vrai qu'ici au sénat ou à
l'assemblée il faut être d'un calme
olympien il faut avoir une très très
bonne relation avec avec les
parlementaires on ne doute pas que vous
ayez se calme olympien
mais est-ce que c'est facile quand on a
une très large majorité comme vous
l'avez en tout cas l'assemblée
mais peut-être plus difficile au sénat
côté la situation politique se sont
différentes
naturellement entre la situation de
l'assemblée aujourd'hui est celle du et
celle du sénat
est-ce que c'est plus difficile je ne
crois pas parce que chaque assemblée à
son propre rythme c'est sa propre
culture
moi je m'adapte à ce rythme et et à
cette culture
on aura l'occasion d'y revenir mais je
pense que pour beaucoup de gens le rôle
de ministre des relations avec le
parlement est un peu difficile à
comprendre
en deux mots c'est confus une sorte de
go-between ont fait des allers retours
au cours d'un groupe à l'autre et puis
au ministère et puis on vient défendre
la loi la majorité il faut d'abord
comprendre ce que c'est le seul ministre
délégué auprès du premier ministre il ya
donc une relation étroite entre l'action
de matignon et notre travail
mon propre directeur de cabinet
participe au cabinet de matignon dont
nous sommes au coeur du fonctionnement
de l'état et très associé c'est pour moi
une découverte de l'importance de ce
rôle qui n'est pas simplement d'abord
effectivement d'organiser de participer
à l'organisation voudront partir un rôle
de relations publiques
non pas du tout c'est beaucoup plus
politique qu'on ne croit y compris avec
un travail en amont avec les cabinets
des autres ministres très simplement
c'est pas simplement un travail
d'intendance ou d'organisation des
assemblées c'est très politique vous
êtes aussi en relation avec l'opposition
vous est peut-être le seul ministre un
petit plus qui fait plus intimes de sa
relation avec l'opposition il faut
parler avec eux donnent un exemple par
exemple aujourd'hui je leur dis voilà
pour les journées parlementaires ça
serait bien qu'elle soit pas éparpiller
sur en moi et qu'on essaye de se mettre
d'accord pour tous les
les faire en même temps sur une période
limitée c'est de l'intérêt collectif
moussa koussa l'ump ou pas ne change ait
pas de réponse mais je suis aller
gentiment le leur proposait je ne doute
pas que dans l'intérêt général et
répondront pas vraiment une opposition
qui risque de vous donner du fil à
retorde on aura l'occasion d'en parler
dans cette émission est déjà d'en avoir
un aperçu
on va évidemment d'abord commencé avec
le lundi quand didier migaud fait ses
comptes
c'était un rapport programme est attendu
la cour des comptes présente un audit
détaillé des finances publiques
situation préoccupante mais pas
catastrophique estime en substance la
cour les objectifs peuvent être tenues
si l'on trouve 6 à 10 milliards en 2012
et surtout 33 milliards en 2013 la
potion du docteur meego c'est un sujet
de marib remo la tâche s'annonce immense
l'équation budgétaire difficile
didier migaud a dévoilé le rapport de la
cour des comptes un rapport sans
concession qui prône très clairement la
rigueur à tous les niveaux pour l'année
2013 année cruciale où il faudra
redoubler d'efforts l'effort estimé à 33
milliards d'euros
si la croissance économique est de 1%
est cependant nécessaire est réalisable
la cour des comptes donne quelques
pistes à suivre du côté des dépenses
tout d'abord toutes les administrations
tous les services à vont devoir se
serrer la ceinture mais la sécurité
sociale devra particulièrement faire
attention et freiner les dépenses
les collectivités territoriales sont
également mis à la diète la cour suggère
une baisse massive des dépenses de
fonctionnement
mais didier migaud a particulièrement
insisté sur un point le principal enjeu
budgétaire porte sur la masse salariale
en effet ces dépenses y compris les
pensions représente 13,6 pour cent du
pipe toute administration confondus
en clair il va falloir supprimer des
postes de fonctionnaires de 15000 à
30000 pas
mais les propositions des sages de la
rue cambon ne s'arrête pas là
l'augmentation des recettes c'est-à-dire
des impôts est inévitable suppression
totale des niches fiscales et sociales
augmentation au moins temporaire de la
tva et de la csg
avec ce rapport la cour des comptes nous
rappelle que pour sortir de la crise
l'essentiel du chemin reste devant nous
alors potion amère à venir va revenir
tout à l'heure avec le collectif
budgétaire sur les mesures à prendre
pour ramener les déficits au niveau
exigé par l'europe juste peut-être
d'avoir une question sur l'héritage
finalement la cour des comptes donne
finale statisfait site gouvernement
fillon est en tout cas à la capacité
qu'il a eue de garder les déficits 2012
de façon raisonnable
il n'est pas allé un peu vite pierre
moscovici quand il a dit je cite la
droite n'avait rien foutu pour réduire
les déficits un peu malade si nous
sommes obligés ce que la question qui
est devant nous de trouver 9 milliards 7
milliards parce qu'il ya eu une erreur
sur une surestimation de la croissance
et de milliards parce qu'il y avait des
dépenses dans financé sait bien que
c'est quelqu'un de café sterrad r une
surestimation de la croissance s'est un
peu dans l'air du temps c'est dans l'air
du nord j'espère que ça allait plus et
que dans tous les cas les donneurs de
leçons d'hier ne vont pas continuer sur
ce terrain aujourd'hui c'était le jeune
croissance peut être l'un des prochains
qui seront qu'ils sont peut-être des
faits ou sur ont surestimé
elles sont alors les injustes ils ont
fait de budget sur 0 7% de prévisions
quand nous mais nous sommes rentrés dans
la campagne électorale au mois de
janvier on avait de nous mêmes dit ça
sera pas à 0,7 on a fait nos calculs sur
ce 05
ces calculs sont en encore faux puisque
ça sera ça sera 0,3 mais dès qu'on le
sait c'est à dire dès maintenant on
réajuste il aurait été normal et
responsable que quand on savait déjà que
ça ne serait pas 0,7
la majorité de droite de l'époque ajusté
ne nous laisse pas la facture puisque au
fond c'est la facture plus 2 milliards
quand même c'est pas énorme
on attendait quand même 2 milliards de
dépenses par exemple le dixième mois de
bourses scolaires
je pourrais donner d'autres exemples qui
ont été annoncées à droite et jamais
financé alors on attendait didier migaud
qui a été très écouté nos rapports qui
était très attendu
est ce que c'est la cour des comptes un
petit peu de dicter la ligne de conduite
du gouvernement
pas du tout la cour des comptes ce sont
1 des comptables doit faire une
photographie à un moment donné de ce qui
se passe ils peuvent faire des
recommandations et je pense qu'elles ne
sont pas sorties de leur rôle mais
naturellement ce qu'ils doivent prendre
les décisions c'est les assembler pour
ce qui concerne le domaine législatif et
le gouvernement en ce qui concerne le
domaine réglementaire la responsabilité
politique des décisions incombe à ceux
qui ont la légitimité pour le faire
c'est à dire ceux qui sont issus du
suffrage universel
alors on va passer au mardi à
l'assemblée nationale eh bien c'est le
grand jour c'est le grand oral du
premier ministre 1h30 ce fut la durée du
discours de politique générale de jean
marc ayrault ce mardi dans un hémicycle
archicomble exercice traditionnel de
tout nouveau premier ministre pour
présenter les grandes lignes de son
programme
1h30 attentivement suivie par paul
bouffard plus d'une heure et demie de
grand oral avec beaucoup de sérieux dans
le style et surtout sans effet de manche
jean marc ayrault livrent les grands
axes du quinquennat et déroule sa
feuille de route sur un ton volontaire
il sonne la mobilisation
le socialiste en appelle au patriotisme
économique loin de faire de la finance
son adversaire non je ne suis pas les
mets de l'argent
mais je ne considère pas les gens
auxquels je parle en fonction de leur
patrimoine et de leurs revenus
patriotisme fiscales aussi le premier
ministre veut la vérité maîtrise des
dépenses publiques oui mais nouvelles
recettes fiscales aussi
la volonté du gouvernement la volonté du
gouvernement
le seul gouvernement c'est de solliciter
d'abord ceux qui jusqu'ici ont été
exonérés de l'effort collectif rompre
avec le style sarkozy dans son discours
jean marc ayrault ne veut pas combattre
l'inertie par l'agitation
il veut prendre le temps d'écouter
d'évaluer de décider les français ne
nous ont pas donné un mandat pour
gouverner sans jour mesdames et
messieurs les députés mais cinq ans
prendre le temps sans rigueur ni
austérité le quinquennat est placée sous
le signe de la justice 45 secondes
d'applaudissements
les députés de la majorité se lève alors
sans surprise très confortable majorité
pour le vote de confiance 302 voix pour
225 compte sur 5 144 votants vous y
étiez évidemment et je connais déjà la
réponse
il a réussi l'exercice parce que comme
il ya une petite critique qu'on a
entendus sur le fait qu'il était encore
un peu trop président de groupe
socialiste que réellement prémices
notamment dans les tacles qui l'a fait
sur le précédent gouvernement le premier
ministre chef de la majorité
il est quand même pas interdit au
premier ministre de critiquer l'action
du gouvernement en la précédent c'est
d'ailleurs tout ce qu'on a fait pendant
la campagne électorale pour le faire ne
voit pas naturellement naturellement
puisque on compare des politiques très
honnêtement c'est un homme très mesuré
sérieux responsable il a été ce qu'il
est c'est à dire je crois vraiment
profondément l'homme du moment de la
situation aujourd'hui en france il
correspond à ce qu'on doit faire
le redressement dans la justice je crois
qu'il est capable de l'incarner et qu'
il a à la fois les propositions le fond
mais aussi la personnalité pour le faire
et je crois que ça s'est ressenti et il
a été lui-même la vie d'avis quand on
réécoute les précédents discours de
politique générale que ce soit de pierre
bérégovoy dominique de villepin même
lionel jospin qu'on disait un petit peu
austère ça manquait peut-être un petit
peu de rêve est ce que c'est la
politique du moment qui fait qu'il n'ya
pas de rêve
et chacun à son appréciation mais moment
lille le moment oui mais si vous relisez
le discours et s'il n'y avait pas eu
quelques perturbations permanente de la
part de l'opposition pour des raisons
qui lui appartiennent
est-ce quelqu'un aime et et la
singularité de ce discours l'absence
l'absence de respect des cris en
permanence assez singulier d'ailleurs y
compris sur le fait qu' on dise mais
enfin les droits de l'opposition sont
bafoués alors que dans le débat qui va
suivre
l'orateur principal que nous étions
prêts à écouter de l'ump n'a même pas
utilisé tout son temps de parole
une incohérence le chahut le chariot sur
les bancs de l'assemblée nationale où
vous étiez dans l'opposition vous savez
ce que c'est le ch a eu la réaction à
des propositions face à fait partie du
débat et je ne fais pas critique de ça
mais laissée dans un groupe quelques
individus en permanence persiflé parfois
injurié comme ça s'est passé je crois
que c'est pas à nous à faire la police
de l'assemblée naturellement c'est la
responsabilité du président mais je
pense aussi du président du groupe le
groupe ump pour revenir un instant sur
le discours de politique générale on
voit qu'il ya vraiment beaucoup de
difficultés pour jean marc ayrault a
prononcé les mots d'austérité et de
rigueur
est-ce que pourquoi voulez vous qu'il le
prononce avec 33 milliards de dinars en
lice g il n'est pas obligé de sacrifier
est-ce que vous lui demander où est ce
que lui demande les gens qui critiquent
sa politique
c'est simplement réaliste mais pas du
tout je ne vois pas pourquoi je ne vois
pas pourquoi on irait qualifié cette
politique d'austérité
écoutez de réduire leurs bandeaux
sécurité parlant d' austérité d'abord la
paix ou de rigueur la principale mesure
c'est quoi c'est de supprimer
l'augmentation de la tva au 1er octobre
donc si on n'aime pas si on ne vient pas
pour des gens ça veut dire quoi un
couple qui travaille et qui gagne deux
fois le smig
la proportion de dépenses qu'ils font
ils seraient soumises à cette
augmentation de la tva c'est 70 euros
d'économie par mois ça fait 8 sans
parler ce message
vous voulez parler de rigueur je dire de
la rigueur et les sobriquets
effectivement si on avait laissé
appliquée mais ce qu'avait fait la
droite
ces 11 milliards qu'on redonne aux
familles et l'ensemble du collectif
c'est 7 milliards 1 voulait pas parler
de rigueur ou d'austérité mais écoutez
quand même vos alliés du parti
communiste qui eux et bien emploie ce
mot de rigueur relève et coûteux nous
craignons vraiment que vos orientations
monsieur le premier ministre
conduisent à l'opposé du résultat
escompté et nous le craignons d'autant
plus que vous ne desserrer pas l'étau de
la contrainte extérieure
voilà pourquoi les députés front de
gauche s'abstiendront aujourd'hui sur
cette vote de confiance sur le fond à
partir du moment où cet accord ou traité
sarkozy merkel au niveau de l'europe et
on ne revient pas sur la réduction des
dépenses publiques
on va vers une politique d'austérité et
donc on sait bien qu une politique
d'austérité c'est la récession alain
vidalies ou les avoir entendu deux se
sont abstenus lors du vote de confiance
vous connaissez cette citation qui dit
occupez vous de mes amis mes amis mes
ennemis je m'en occupe
c'est un petit peu ça avec les
communistes notamment il s'est pas
sénile dans une situation politique
particulière ils sont pas membres du
gouvernement ils soudent sont dans la
majorité présidentielle puisqu'ils ont
contribué à l'élection et ils ont
souhaité eux mêmes parce que ils
estiment avoir des différences voire des
divergences avec nous et notamment sur
la question du traité européen ou de la
politique à conduire de finalement avoir
une sorte de soutien en cas par cas de
ne pas évidemment se situer s'est pas
totalement une surprise une situation
politique est connue depuis le départ et
nous essayons de maintenir le dialogue
avec eux d'être le plus souvent d'accord
avec eux mais je vous dis rien la risle
nouveau sous le soleil
est ce que vous avez peut-être est
nouveau mais ce que vous pensez que
c'est aussi une stratégie politique vous
êtes majoritaires sans eux
est ce que vous voyez là aussi une
stratégie quelque part ne leur pas oui
pour exister
pourquoi voulez vous que ce soit une
stratégie ils sont fidèles à ce qu'ils
ont dit pendant la campagne électorale
ils sont ils sont en situation de
cohérence nous aussi et donc on continue
le dialogue mais
personne ne renie rien et chacun est
fidèle à ce qu'il est aussi le cas des
écologistes qui sont forts de leurs 17
17 membres
ils ont voté cette fois ci la confiance
au gouvernement héros mais on a bien
senti dans la déclaration de françois de
rugy coprésident du groupe que ce serait
à l'avenir sous conditions bien précises
ce sont vraiment des alliés les écolos
vous pensé pour la suite c'est des
alliés très clairement puisque l'on a
signé avec un contrat de gouvernement
ils ont été candidats à un autre nom
dans un certain nombre de
circonscriptions et dès le premier tour
donc c'est des alliés vraiment qui ont
été prises en compte et donc leur
engagement qui a été réitérée y compris
lorsqu'il ya eu une polémique à la suite
à quelques unes de médias et revenir qui
c'est qui qui était clair je renvoie
tout le monde aux scripts parce que ça
permet tait si on résume un petit peu
vous avez dit un des différences oui
mais la liberté de vote non c'est bien
résumé paddy fait résumé pas du tout
aller reprenez le script de l'émission
était d'ailleurs sur des chasseurs sont
prêts à faire j'ai dit très clairement
que sur le vote du budget sur le vote de
la loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale et sur la confiance au
gouvernement
évidemment compte tenu du contrat qui
nous lie il ne peut pas y avoir de
liberté de vote sur ces sur ces trois
questions là il ya eu tout un buzz
autour de mes déclarations et ensuite le
président de l'assemblée nationale redit
à la même émission la semaine d'après la
même chose le journaliste dit vous êtes
donc d'accord avec alain vidalis il a
dit oui le plus personne n'a réagi et
j'ai entendu la déclaration du nouveau
responsable des verts qui a dit
exactement la même chose que ce que ça
dit la différence est une richesse donc
mais la différence est une richesse bien
sûr chacun y voit ce qu'il veut
finalement non non je pense que les
choses sont claires on a fait un accord
le contenu de cet accord c'est qu'on
s'engage sur les votes essentiel
j'ai la sécurité sociale et la confiance
au gouvernement et pour le reste il ya
les 60 ans de logements qui me
semble-t-il font notre règle commune je
voudrais pas aussi où il ya une fille il
ya une majorité de gauche au sens large
qui qui qui est éclatée en quatre
groupes
alors éclaté vous avez certes la
majorité absolue dont vous n'avez guère
de souci à vous faire
sauf que finalement ces groupes peuvent
exister à l'assemblée de façon très très
marqué avec notamment ils peuvent
demander un droit de tirage avec des
commission denquête ils ont ils auront
des droits de parole des sommets
d'initiative parlementaire
si vous ne craignez pas un petit peu se
produisent trop de bruit on de liberté
non est ce que la diversité va nuire à
l'efficacité gens n'en suis pas sûr
l'ennui naquit un jour de l'uniformité
donc notera aura la majorité
vivante et en même temps sorel puisque
le groupe socialiste avait beaucoup de
travail et j'aurai beaucoup à propos de
sérénité vous en avez déjà un peu parlé
tout à l'heure le groupe ump dans tout
ça ils sont 196 députés si on inclut les
apparentés pas assez nombreux avec les
centristes pour mettre en difficulté les
socialistes certes mais déjà bien décidé
à ne pas rester muet le premier ministre
en a eu un avant goût prononcé dès ce
mardi vous l'avais déjà dit céline
bittner désormais en minorité n'est pas
sans joie pendant tout le discours de
politique générale
les députés ump se sont fait entendre
jusqu'à chahuté à plusieurs reprises le
nouveau premier ministre
je tiendrai informé nos concitoyens à
travers la représentation nationale
je le ferais régulièrement mes chers
collègues mes chers collègues
sitôt le discours de jean marc ayrault
terminé la droite quitte l'hémicycle en
masse les ténors de l'ump le sable c'est
désormais dans les couloirs de
l'assemblée que tout se passe à question
de laisser le champ libre aux
socialistes
j'ai découvert un premier ministre
complètement prisonnier d'une vision
franco française assez idéologique et
qui derrière les franges les grandes
phrases en réalité n'annonce aucune
réformes courageuses je suis donc
malheureusement très déçu il annonce
encore des nouveaux programmes des plans
des réformes coûteuses et il ne nous dit
pas un seul instant
qui va payer pour ces réformes aussi
long et aussi nul
le propos la premier ministre le jeu ne
l'est jamais vu anciens ministres cadres
de l'ump
ils défilent tous devant les
journalistes chacun veut continuer à
exister
la droite dénonce les hausses d'impôts
mais aussi le manque de clarté du
premier ministre sur les moyens de
réduire le déficit public
un constat partagé par le nouveau patron
des centristes à l'assemblée mais de
grâce vous pouvez pas défendre le
pouvoir d'achat et le travail et
alourdir les charges et la fiscalité sur
les heures supplémentaires
tu parles de grand capital centriste ump
chacun essaie de trouver son style et
son rôle dans la nouvelle opposition
mais tous ont voulu montrer que les
socialistes devront compter sur eux
alors quitté l'hémicycle en groupe
elles y ont pris goût puisque dès le
lendemain ils ont renouvelé l'opération
lors du débat sans vote sur l'europe
ils étaient cette fois ci mais content
qu'il n'y ait pas de questions au
gouvernement
ce qui d'ailleurs est été difficile
puisque le premier ministre était au
même moment au sénat on y reviendra à la
vie d'alice on entend toujours la
nouvelle opposition dire qu'elle sera
constructive mesurer c'est un leurre
c'est toujours alors quelle que soit la
majorité l'opposition
je dois dire que c'est quand même pas
l'image qu'ils ont donné chacun se pose
comme il veut mais quand j'entends le
caractère très dur on sait les propos y
compris des anciens ministres il
s'interrogea encore pour savoir pourquoi
ils ont perdu je les invite à réexaminer
leur mode d'expression franchement
tout à l'heure vous parliez du président
de groupe ump christian jacob ou dit
quoi il ne tient pas ses troupes
si je pense qu'au contraire ils étaient
plutôt sceptiques ont déjà coûté selon
lui bah oui parce que dix compétitions
elle passe d'y montrer du doigt tout le
monde que tous ceux qui étaient dans
l'assemblée ont bien vu qu'il y avait
deux trois députés quand il n'y avait
pas france aura des spécialistes des
débats et des interventions de fond et
qui donc s'exprime avec le talent qu'il
reste donc je crois que franchement bon
c'est pas c'est pas nous à faire des
observations mais que tout le monde le
sait que ce serait quand même juste pour
qu'on comprenne bien votre rôle est la
vie d'alice c'est aussi d'avoir des
bonnes relations avec christian jacob
est de faire se trouvait aussi les
députés dents dans l'opposition qui vont
pouvoir mener des débats constructifs
ce aussi votre rôle vous êtes en contact
avec l'europe c'est d'avoir un bon
contact avec pour tout ce qui relève de
décisions communes mais certainement pas
d'essayer de le mettre en place je sais
quelle influence sur la façon de
s'opposer l'opposition décident seuls
est à la fois du fonds est à la fois de
la foi alors on va passer au mercredi
l'assemblée nationale se penche sur le
budget 2012
le conseil des ministres examine ce
mercredi matin le collectif budgétaire
pour 2012 7,2 milliards d'impôts en plus
qui consiste pour partie en détricotage
des mesures emblématiques de l'ère
sarkozy sur fond de croissance révisée à
la baisse
chloé buffard c'est le premier tour de
vis budgétaire annoncé par le
gouvernement héros objectif réduire le
déficit malgré une croissance en berne
les prévisions pour 2012 ont été revues
à la baisse 0,3 pour cent contre 0,7
prévu par le gouvernement fillon
ce que nous voulons c'est l'équilibré
équilibre entre les dépenses et les
recettes équilibre entre le secteur
privé et
le secteur public équilibre au sein du
secteur public équilibre entre les
entreprises et les ménages pourquoi une
politique qui soit à la fois une
politique qui soutiennent la croissance
grâce est fondamental qui permettent la
justice sociale et puis qui redresse les
comptes publics
un contexte économique tendu l'argent
rentre donc moins dans les caisses de
l'état
le gouvernement mise sur des hausses
d'impôts visant en priorité les plus
riches contributions exceptionnelles
pour les contribuables soumis à l'isf
l'impôt de solidarité sur la fortune et
les grosses successions ou donations
seront davantage taxées pour imprimer sa
marque
la nouvelle majorité revient sur deux
mesures phare de l'ère sarkozy la tva
dite sociale sera supprimé et
l'exonération des heures supplémentaires
annulées dans les entreprises de plus de
20 salariés
on met devant les quelques mesures sur
les riches pour mieux camoufler toutes
celles qui tombent sur les classes
moyennes et les familles modestes
l'ambulancier le chauffeur routier
le salarié de chez michelin lui il va
déguster
il va perdre ses heures supplémentaires
il va perdre sa participation il va
perdre son intéressement
il va perdre l'actionnariat salarié les
hausses d'impôts devrait rapporter 7,2
milliards d'euros cette année a ajouté
ou 1,5 milliard d'euros de gel des
dépenses supplémentaires
l'état table donc sur une économie de
8,7 milliards d'euros pour boucler le
budget 2012 alors nous y voici dans ces
fameuses mesures vous avez entendu
laurent wauquiez à la fin de la
défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires la plus forte taxation
de l'intéressement dès 2012 donc ça ce
sont des mesures qui vont aussi toucher
les classes moyennes qui vont aussi
toucher certains salariés dans une
situation qui n'est pas forcément juste
aujourd'hui qu'elle est quel est le
problème nous avons des déficits
notamment dans la sécurité sociale
l'intéressement et la participation
nous souhaitons les maintenir
aujourd'hui que l'intéressement et la
participation c'est de la rémunération
mais sur lesquels les cotisations qui
sont payés pour financer la sécurité
sociale sont très inférieurs à ceux qui
est payé pour l'aider
les rémunérations normal quand on
regarde de près ce qui se passe on voit
que ces concentrés dans les grandes
entreprises
très peu dans les petites entreprises
dont les salariés des petites
entreprises ceux qui sont les moins
payés en bénéficient de moi et puis
c'est une forme non pas d'évasion mais
pas loin c'est à dire qu'il ya une
technique pour payer le moins de
cotisations possibles qui font que le
différentiel doit être diminuée dans les
cours et sur la défiscalisation des
heures supplémentaires
monsieur wauquiez est toujours très
nuancée dit ils vont perdre leurs heures
supplémentaires ou simplement dire qu'on
n'a pas décidé de supprimer les heures
supplémentaires de récupération des
sommes d'argent la fin du mois comme on
va remettre les cotisations sur les
heures supplémentaires
on nous dit ah oui mais les gens les
salariés etc lesquels et ceux qui en
font jamais est-ce qu'il faut rappeler
est-ce qu'il faut rappeler que il ya 56
% des salariés ils font jamais d'art
supplémentaires parce qu'ils sont dans
des métiers où on en fait pas effet
parce qu'ils n'ont pas besoin mais ceux
qui ont une canne besoin c'est
l'employeur qui décide
est-ce que vous avez déjà entendu un
salarié qui pouvait lire à écouter j'ai
des besoins j'ai des crédits à faire je
veux faire des heures supplémentaires
non c'est l'employeur qui décide et même
le salarié n'a pas le droit de refuser
donc la question des heures
supplémentaires quand vous êtes en
situation de plein emploi ou que ça va
bien elle allait l'extrême limite début
des mules 2007
bon j'étais content sur le principe mais
franchement est ce qu'il y à un pays qui
a osé faire quelque chose on a dépensé
quatre milliards 4 milliards par an ne
pas depuis 2007 pour financer cette
affaire qui est une horreur on finance
le chômage sur fonds publics les
allemands ont financé le chômage partiel
est ce que vous croyez pas est ce que
vous croyez pas qu'on aurait pu utiliser
cet argent pour financer davantage le
chômage partiel on a dépensé nous un
milliard par an les allemandes 10
milliards à la vie d'alice ça c'est pour
les heures supplémentaires
vous avez décidé d'augmenter la tva
aussi mais la csg le ministre l'économie
dit
et pourquoi pas dans les prochaines les
prochains mois c'est une éventualité
c'est pourquoi aux de la cg j'ai pas lu
cette déclaration j'ai même lu lé
inverse puisqu'il a dit qu'il n'était
pas question en 2013 de jeudi matin sur
une radio
non après après 2013 il a dit jusque là
c'est envisageable pour le gouvernent la
question de la csg peut se poser
effectivement sur des questions de
transfert c'est à dire que si on change
l'assiette de financement de la
protection sociale saisie pas
d'augmenter le prélèvement global
il s'agit de transférer des cotisations
éventuellement sur la cg c'est un des
débats mais c'est pas une réponse que le
gouvernement va apporter ça va c'est une
porte ouverte pour éventuellement ses
personnages et c'est un sujet de
négociation entre les partenaires
sociaux là puisque cette question-là
fait partie c'est aussi un changement de
méthode qui est très important de la
conférence de la conférence sociale qui
vous laisse mon projet très rapidement
et puis beaucoup de temps sur ce sujet
on a baissé la tva sociale faisait
baisser la tva en supprimant la tva
sociale cette année une hausse de la tva
est totalement à exclure en 2013
on sait que c'est un fait et de revenir
le précieux qui est important c'est de
rappeler je l' ai déjà dit j'y reviens
pas mais on redonne 11 milliards de
pouvoir d'achat qui avait été supprimé
pour l'ensemble des ménages y compris
les classes moyennes alors après
l'assemblée nationale c'est au tour du
sénat au lendemain de son discours de
politique générale jean marc ayrault a
pris la parole devant les sénateurs pour
sa première à la chambre haute
le premier ministre a prononcé un
discours moins long que la veille et
plus axé sur les collectivités locales
et les territoires la majorité applaudit
l'opposition est bien là aussi à jouer
les trouble-fête nous lire ceci
avant son grand oral le premier ministre
revoit ses notes
guidés par le président du sénat jean
marc ayrault pur produit de l'assemblée
nationale fait ses premiers pas au
palais du luxembourg
une terre presque inconnue pour le chef
du gouvernement mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs le sur eux d'abord de vous
saluer je dois dire que pour moi c'est
assez impressionnant c'est la première
fois que je parle devant cette haute
assemblée
mais plus disciplinés que leurs
collègues députés pendant le discours
une fois sortis de l'hémicycle les
sénateurs de l'opposition ont déjà des
reproches adressés au chef du
gouvernement que dès le départ il n'a
pas voulu nous considérer au niveau où
ils devaient nous considérer nous sommes
la haute assemblée il devait demander un
vote à tous les sénateurs sur son
discours de politique générale il ne l'a
pas fait et à partir de là tout à
affaiblir fort et il aura réussi son
examen de passage quand il montrera des
vrais signes de respect à l'égard du
sénat ce qui est pas le cap soit en
refusant de faire voter le sénat pour
des raisons purement politiciennes et de
tactiques interne
ils montrent très clairement qu'il n'a
aucune considération commission pour le
sénat pour saisir les codes et les
coutumes du sénat jean marc ayrault
pourra compter sur les conseils
d'anciens la maison aujourd'hui au
gouvernement il y a en général une
approche plus on va dire subtil que dans
d'autres chambres
il faut bien connaître les rouages les
équilibres politiques qui sont beaucoup
plus fin qui ne le sont à l'assemblée
nationale car s'il dispose d'une
majorité confortable à l'assemblée
nationale le premier ministre devra
composer avec toutes les sensibilités de
ses alliés ici la majorité ne tient qu'à
si vous après vous avez entendu à ces
sénateurs qui ne se sentent pas
considérer pourquoi est ce qu'il n'ya
pas une vote au sénat vote au sénat
parce que la déclaration de politique
générale et la sanction de cette pauline
de cette déclaration appartient à
l'assemblée nationale les conséquences
d'un vote positif ou négatif au sénat
sont institutionnellement inexistante
c'est si le cdh si l'assemblée nationale
vote contre le gouvernement et anvers
pour le symbole oui françois fillon
l'avait fait mais sur d'autres sujets il
l'a pas fait par exemple sur
l'afghanistan il n'a eu ni ne l'avait
pas fait il avait utilisé l'article 50,1
donc je n'accepte pas l'idée qu'il y
aurait une déconsidération je dois même
dire pour être très clair que ce que
j'entends c'est que le premier mythe de
la part des députés de droite c'est que
le premier ministre a été beaucoup trop
au sénat mardi et mercredi et dès que
d'ailleurs il faudrait que l'ump se met
d'accord parce qu'on ne peut pas nous
reprocher d'être venu deux fois le
premier ministre en personne au sénat
pour marquer sa considération et de ne
pas avoir le même jour organiser une
question d'actualité à l'assemblée
nationale
c'était peut-être aussi une séance de
rattrapage pour premise qui a oublié les
sénateurs dans son premier gouvernement
juppé faut peut-être y voir ça aussi à
mon écoute et le commentaire à le
commentaire est libre mais franchement
je ne suis pas sûr qu'ils aient une
séquence aussi avec l'otan de
considération pour le sénat et ce qui a
été fait par le premier ministre mardi
et maintenant alors dans son discours
sur le fond cette fois jean marc ayrault
a annoncé deux thèmes très important les
collectivités locales avec cet acte iii
de la décentralisation est ce que vous
connaissez le calendrier
jusqu'où et autres thèmes et là vous me
répondrez aussi c'est la fin du
conseiller territorial ça sera voté
quand c'est la fin du conseiller
territorial ce sera votée quand je peux
pas vous donner une réponse précise
n'est pas arrêtée dans tous les cas il
ya un calendrier condren puisqu'il faut
que ce soit voté au plus tard au mois de
mars 2013 donc ça va aller assez vite et
vous le savez puisque le sénat a pris
des initiatives la majorité du sénat
il y aura des états généraux de la
démocratie locale et qui viendront
finaliser ce travail important qui a été
engagé par le sénat qui auront lieu au
mois de septembre d'octobre est donc
finalement après ces états généraux
je pense qu'on sera en situation
d'avancé sur des questions qui restent à
portée d'un mot est ce que vous
confirmez aussi que les élections
cantonales et régionales seront
repoussées je ne confirme pas ça fait
partie des hypothèses de travail
aujourd'hui
vous le savez qu'il y aurait une sorte
d'encombrements sur 2000 sur 2014 ce qui
tient plutôt la corde comme solution
c'est de maintenir les élections
municipales et éventuellement de
reporter les deux autres élections mais
ne prenez pas ça pour une annonce
puisque c'est aujourd'hui ça reste une
hypothèse de travail d'alors jean marc
ayrault a annoncé aussi au sénat que
l'application de la règle du non cumul
des mandats ce serait pour 2014 c'était
une promesse du candidat hollande pas de
cumul d'un mandat parlementaire avec un
mandat exécutif local
une annonce qui passe plutôt mal c'est
un sujet qui fâche elisa barthoulot mich
il sera mis fin au cumul entre un mandat
de parlementaire et l'exercice de
fonctions exécutives locales pour que
cela soit effectif est applicable avant
applaudissements nourris du côté des
écologistes moqueries sur les bancs de
la droite hésitation chez les
socialistes
le sénat est loin d'être favorable à la
limitation du cumul des mandats
et pour cause nombre de sénateurs son
président de région de département ou
maire d'une grande ville
lyon marseille dijon arguments des élus
le sénat représente les collectivités
locales
pas question donc pour les sénateurs de
se couper des territoires shiqiang pêche
parlementaires de faire du travail de
bonne qualité c'est être coupé des
réalités du terrain de passer sa vie à
paris et de ne plus savoir ce qui se
passe chez lui de ne plus savoir ce que
pense et ce que soient nos concitoyens
et de le même puissant pour le sénateur
ce qu'une collectivité alors que nous
représentons dans les communes de france
les discussions sur le texte s'annonce
donc houleuse
la majorité sénatoriale est loin d'être
unanimes si les écologistes ils sont
réellement favorable
les radicaux refusent de voter la
moindre limitation du nombre de mandats
les socialistes eux sont partagés projet
de loi va être votée l'année prochaine
pas cette année
d'ici là on aura fait valoir tous nos
arguments je sais bien qu'aujourd'hui la
demande la demande citoyenne et vers le
mandat unique encore jeu le jeu le mode
r parce que c'est sans doute une demande
des militants
moi j'ai pas entendu tous les jours sur
le terrain les citoyens me demandait le
monde a unique pourtant selon un récent
sondage 92% des français sont pour
limiter le nombre de mandats
les principaux concernés sont loin
d'atteindre cette proportion dernier
encore est ce que vous êtes sûr que ce
projet fera adopter au sénat
on pense plutôt inverse sur eux n'est
jamais sûr de rien ce qui compte c'est
que le président de la république et le
gouvernement tiennent leurs engagements
il ya un engagement sur la limitation du
cumul des mandats il y aura donc un taxi
un vrai risque que le texte soit
retoquée au sénat tels qu'on les voit
déjà réagir aujourd'hui c'est à nous
d'être à la fois convaincant et d'ouvrir
la discussion
on connaît l'objectif les modalités
restent à discuter
vous savez parfaitement il ya la
question du curseur par exemple de
survie élections on le principal vous a
placé le débat est ouvert il n'y a pas
eu d'engagement de prix lescure one
curseur ou pas à quel niveau il peut
être important
l'idée c'est de dire pour l'essentiel
que un exécutif local et un mandat
parlementaire soit incompatible
après tout même avait été député et
conseiller général si je ne me trompe
oui mais j'ai fini par être convaincu de
ceux de cette démarche et je me suis
présenté un ayant abandonné tous mes
mandats locaux vous pensez c'est un
combat que ted accompagné vraiment je
pense qu'un mandat sans exécutif parce
qu'il faut voir ce que dit le texte
c'est pas la même chose d'être
conseiller général où ça me paraît
compatible ou peut-être que la question
du mandat unique est effectivement un
peu forte mais après être dans un
exécutif c'est autre chose
effectivement j'ai un moment donné était
parlementaire et premier vice-président
du conseil général chargé des affaires
sociales
ce qui n'était pas rien bon ça suppose
des arbitrages d'emploi du temps qui
sont pas forcément compatibles
vous attendez dans ce reportage de
sénateurs patriat qui disait c'est
difficile finalement ni moins d'être un
élu local et de représenter 7
cette localité au sénat dans l'ensemble
de la nation
c'est pas simple un parlement mais pour
eux leur choix sans un parlementaire est
un élu de la nation et représentant d'un
territoire je pense qu'il faut rappeler
ses fondamentaux sur ce qui est d'abord
le rôle du parlementaire
et il ya aussi une spécificité du cnra
conseil des communes de france
donc est ce que cette spécificité sera
reconnue dans la loi ça fait partie ça
fait partie du débat que nous avons que
nous avons devant nous mais je pense
qu'il ya une attente de nos concitoyens
sur cette question là et il faut quand
même le rappeler il ya une spécificité
française
on est le seul pays en europe à avoir un
cumul des mandats de cette importance
ailleurs cette question ne se pose plus
et depuis longtemps vous reconnaissez
quand même qu'il y aura des heures
chaudes pour vous miner les relations
parlement sur ce dossier est intéressant
presque chaud d'ailleurs le débat sur
l'europe s'invite au sénat nous sommes
jeudi alors à peine le sommet européen
du 28 et du 29 juin achevé françois
hollande a annoncé qu'il proposerait que
soit soumise au parlement toutes les
décisions concernant l'europe à
l'assemblée et au sénat
un débat sur les résultats de ce sommet
a eu lieu cette fin de semaine le chef
de l'état voudrait lui accélérer et
clore sa séquence européenne du volet
croissance à la taxe sur les
transactions financières et elle est
vive et souhaiterait un vote peut être
dès cet été les réactions et les
explications de venir soucis au sénat
jean marc ayrault vient présenter le
paquet européen que les élus devront
voter un ensemble de textes qui lie le
pacte budgétaires négociés par nicolas
sarkozy aux avancées sur la gestion des
banques et des taxes sur les
transactions financières impulsée par
françois hollande
un moyen de forcer l'opposition à
soutenir l'ensemble il y aura des gens
qui voteront ce traité à l'ump c'est
clair
en particulier bien sûr sur l'espèce il
est acquis l'éveil été négociées en
amont sur les spectacles de croissance
je crois qu'il serait difficile de voter
contre même port des parlementaires de
droite
pas de problème pour certains élus ump
qui veulent se poser sur la question
européenne en opposant constructif
jamais je n'aurais aucun problème à
voter la ratification d'un accord que
j'aurais voté
si nicolas sarkozy était encore
président de la république c'est évident
je réponds à la question posée
je ne réponds pas la personne qui me
pose de la question le gouvernement
cherche à éviter de convoquer le congrès
pour la ratification où une majorité des
3 5e est requise
d'autant que le soutien de tous ses
alliés est loin d'être assurée en l'état
nous ne le voterons pas nous nous y
opposerons aujourd'hui nous pensons
d'ailleurs dans la mesure où je n'ai
certainement pas un débat qui a
transcendé
je dirais la la campagne électorale
qu'il faut venir devant le peuple
français qu'il faut qu'il y ait un débat
national d'importance et qu'ils soient
sanctionnés par un référendum
hors de question pour l'elysée la
blessure de l'échec du référendum de
2005 sur la constitution européenne
reste encore vives dans l'esprit de
françois hollande
alors pour qu'on comprenne bien la
vidalie ce texte il va être présenté
devant le congrès à versailles par voie
référendaire
comment ça va se passer vous devez aussi
saisir le conseil constitutionnel qu'est
ce que c'est fait ou pas alors le
conseil constitutionnel va être saisi ce
n'est pas fait pour l'instant puisqu'il
faut écrire écrire les textes l'ensemble
des textes pas simplement le traité
d'origine mais le résultat de ce que
nous avons pu obtenir au moment du
sommet européen du 28 et 29 juin
nous saisissons le conseil
constitutionnel pourquoi parce que
aujourd'hui il ya un débat pour savoir
si l'adoption de ce traité et du paquet
c'est à dire de l'ensemble des accords
suppose une modification de la
constitution ou pas alors il
débats et cetera mais je vais pas
répondre à la place du conseil
constitutionnel donc en attendant la
décision du conseil constitutionnel
puisque l'us elle va nous dire il faut
modifier la constitution
parce que si on modifie pas la
constitution il ya une autre solution ce
serait de dire que pour remplir les
obligations qui sont dans le traité ce
qu'on appelle la fameuse règle d'or et
que nicolas sarkozy voulait mettre dans
la constitution
est ce qu'une loi organique répond à ces
exigences là ce que nous pensions au
départ donc nous attendons la réponse du
conseil
mais la règle d'or elle et elle est dans
le elle est dans le dans le traité la
question de la règle d'or n'est pas de
savoir si on va l'exclure du traité ou
pas assez de savoir si vous la mettez en
tant que tel dans la constitution ce que
nous on ne souhaite pas ou si vous la
mettez dans une inde dans une dans une
loi organique la deuxième question c'est
beaucoup plus technique c'est que c'est
de savoir est ce que les moules et les
modalités de contrôle des budgets de
chaque état et qui sont prévus par le
traité y compris avec des rectifications
possible est ce que c'est aujourd'hui
des modalités qui porte atteinte à la
souveraineté de la france et donc ils
abandonneraient une partie de sa
souveraineté
ce qui supposerait une modification de
la constitution c'est grand c'est le
conseil constitutionnel qui va répondre
pour nous dire que ce qu'on doit faire
il va répondre quand j'entends parler
demain matin la décision
ça peut être demain matin et ça peut
être de la dore moi car en réalité ce
délai d'un mois et qui prévues pour les
réponses du conseil lorsqu on le saisit
sur des lois ne s'applique pas dans ce
cas là d'une précision juridique peu de
chances pour que ce soit de perdre de la
session du mois de juillet ah ça je vois
pas comment ça pourrait être
j'ai lu ça je suis d'accord je vois pas
encore inscrits cela plusieurs que ça
puisse se faire
là comme ça au moins deux mois de
juillet après et d'idées effectivement
du président de la république c'est deux
choses qui sont claires c'est d'aller le
plus vite possible
et deuxièmement de choisir la voie
parlementaire pour répondre puisque de
toute façon c'était l'engagement qu'il
avait pris pendant la campagne et moi on
va terminer avec une image celle des
obsèques dolly
effet rend ce mercredi à paris à 42 ans
il venait tout juste de faire son entrée
à l'assemblée comme élus des bouches du
rhône beaucoup de personnalités du parti
socialiste était venu lui dire adieu ce
jour là à lui qui était l'un des
penseurs du parti socialiste fondateur
du groupe terra nova et initiateur entre
autres des primaires voilà c'est sur
cette image un peu triste mais vous dire
au revoir à la vie d'alice merci
beaucoup d'avoir répondu à nos questions
merci own on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine alors à la semaine prochaine
le week end à tout savoir